take the FBI already processing 100-plus
leads and now they're also going to have
to deal with comments from the
presumptive candidates for president
we'll see scripted ones later on but
they've both already been talking is
this throwing spanners into the FBI's
investigation no I think the FBI can
probably manage to keep his
investigation pretty clear I think the
FBI's biggest problem right now is
answering the question of what happened
when they questioned the suspect Omar
Martine twice once into 2013 once in
2014 and really found no grounds to hold
him once because of complaint from
co-workers that he was talking about
sort of terrorism and terrorist ties a
second time because they believed he had
some connections to a suicide bomber in
Syria and both times the FBI concluded
they just simply didn't have the
evidence to hold them and what the FBI
has told us since then is they also
don't really have the resources to track
people even once they've sort of come to
their attention so we are expecting to
hear from the FBI later today possibly
as early as noon time to kind of explain
to us how how mr. mateen kind of slipped
through their grasp yeah but how does
something like this move forward because
what kind of legislation can be put in
place to deter something like this from
happening short of more gun control
right and I mean that's and actually
that's what the FBI director James Comey
has told us many times that's stopping
these so-called lone wolf terrorists is
is one of the hardest jobs for his his
agency to do as you can imagine these
are folks that are you know solitary
individuals they can read stuff online
they can communicate possibly with
people overseas and then at some point
that no one can never predict they sort
of break and they go ahead and do these
things that like this horrible thing
that happened in Orlando so it really is
the proverbial needle in a haystack and
you know look it's the United States we
have laws about due process and when you
can hold someone and when you can't and
in this case the FBI is saying you know
they followed all the rules they tried
very hard to figure out this was a
person they needed to pay attention to
and decided concluded they really
couldn't hold him so it is one of the
one of the more tricky parts of that job
Craig a war of words has already ensued
between Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton
what tone and what message will the will
both candidates want to get across when
they speak later
I mean I think we've already had a
pretty good preview of their comments
today from their comments yesterday
Hillary Clinton start with Donald Trump
he actually talked about he actually
called for an Obama to resign because he
failed to use the words radical Islam in
his statement that he gave yesterday
afternoon from the White House he
suggested that Clinton should resign as
well because she hadn't used that term
either Hillary Clinton has you know
talked about the dangers of radical
Islam but she is saying look this is not
a time for partisanship this is a time
for statesmanship where we need to
really come together as a country
Democrats Republicans left right and
figure out how to solve this problem
figure out how to prevent incidents like
this from happening in the future so I
think what you're going to see today is
Hillary Clinton trying to look like the
sort of the steady leader former
Secretary of State of course a person
who can you know sort of keep things
under control Trump is obviously trying
to use this to point out that he thinks
Obama and Clinton hipster the country
wrong aren't doing enough to crack down
on these possible lone wolf terrorists
so it's going to be quite a day in the
political world